some women still struggling to have
their partners with them
for scan appointments and throughout
labour is this acceptable
no it's not acceptable in fact one of
the real concerns we've had
throughout the pandemic has been the
impact
of covid on patients who don't have
covid
and that is because we have a situation
where
the nhs infrastructure is woefully
lacking
in terms of the facilities and doctors
and staff we have
which means that not only are we trying
to
get the surge of cases of covid we have
the second problem of
the backlog of care that is developed
about millions of patients who have not
been seen during the first peak
and now we have the unfortunate prospect
of a challenging winter this is probably
going to be the most difficult period
that doctors will be experiencing in
their lifetimes
approaching winter the most difficult
period so
worse than the first wave well the first
wave came during spring
uh moving to summer what we have now is
an
accumulated uh um numbers of patients
and millions on weight loss there are
over a hundred thousand patients
waiting more than 12 months for
treatment that's more than a hundred
fold than
the summer of last year and we have um
on top of that backlog of the surge in
numbers about
some of the hospitals in the country uh
have about 20 percent of their beds
occupied by coveted patients some are
seeing more covert patients
than they saw during the first peak we
have over 700 patients today on
ventilators
in the beginning of september it was it
was about 70. so you can see this
trajectory is quite alarming
and when you add that together and then
you have every winter of course
increased pressures with more
respiratory illnesses this these three
pressures converging together is placing
the nhs in a very um
you know under under pressure we've not
seen before coming up to winter
you're talking about the impact on
patients who don't have covert 19 as
well and you've done a survey for
members
haven't you about their concerns about
council appointments or other people not
being able to access the nhs and the way
that they should be able to
what does it show so our survey shows
and it's just been published today so
it's very up to date uh from
about thousand uh doctors uh what it
shows is they are extremely worried
about their ability to care in the
coming months you know doctors do not
want
to see patients uh unable to access care
and that refers to cancer patients
heart disease patients patients with
rumors logical conditions they don't
want to be in a position where
there are millions on waiting lists and
not knowing
when they will receive their care and
that's one of the real worries we
mustn't forget
you know that the several million who
are now
waiting for hip operations uh cataracts
etc
they have no idea when they will be seen
uh
and and and what doctors are also
worried about is staffing
at the moment one in four doctors sorry
four in ten doctors tell us
that their clinical colleagues are
absent from work
uh because of self-isolation or because
they are infected themselves
that is adding pressure to a system when
we started before the pandemic
with 10 000 doctor vacancies so there's
a very real issue
about staffing there's also issue about
facilities
and and beds at the moment and nhs
figures say that we will be entering
this winter with fewer beds
than we had last year uh and uh there's
only about
one in three doctors tell us that where
they work
it has sufficient ability to separate
covet
and non-covet patients and let's
remember that in order for infection
prevention control
you can't have hospitals and gp
surgeries operating the same way you you
have to have
fewer patients um less density because
of the need to create that separation
so that we don't see spread in in
hospitals
which also we know has happened in the
past so there are real challenges ahead
and it's really important that the
government
is clear about those challenges and is
clear to the public about what
uh reality is what we feel is absolutely
important
is that anyone with an urgent medical
problem should not be deterred
from contacting the service and the
service must continue to provide that
parallel
service for uh non-nh non-coveted
patients
alongside covid patients we don't want
to go back to
the first peak when we saw uh in march
only 50 percent of patients with heart
attacks attending hospital
we we must make sure that the needs of
patients who are urgently ill
are met this time around whether they
have coveted or not
yeah certainly some really you know
concerning issues
coming this winter and your survey also
shows that doctors seem
quite skeptical about the current
restrictions uh in
particular tier three areas and whether
they will work what kind of concerns are
being raised
i think one our biggest concern is that
what the government has not spelt out
is a proper preventative strategy
there's no point having
a lockdown in tier three and then going
back to the tier one measures
if they were successful uh which which
clearly led to this
what we need is a sustained approach and
we believe that
there are infection control measures
there are uh ways in which to create
covet-secure
environments and we haven't heard any of
that all we've heard is about
acting off the horses bolted uh locking
down an area
and then the worry we have is that after
that we go back to square one so what we
believe is there is a need for much more
much much greater clarity uh and also um
the move from tier one to tier two to d3
is
highly confusing uh we need very clear
trigger points
but but most importantly what happens
after
oh yeah big questions there just very
quickly lots of people will be looking
ahead to christmas wondering
whether they can have anything like a
normal christmas and do you think the
government should temporarily relax the
rules
uh or does that risk a rise in
infections
i think the most important thing is what
the government does today now
if we can and if the government can have
a coherent approach
to ensure that there is proper infection
control measures
uh in society when people go out to work
when people go outside
at the end of the day this there is
actually a very simple message here this
virus cannot spread
if people don't mix and it is possible
we've shown
during the first uh peak that it is
possible
to bring the infection down in july then
that is after the lockdown was ease
we were seeing only 500 new cases
a day we are today seeing uh well over
20
000 on a daily basis 23 000 yesterday so
we need to get back down
to what we achieved before and that is
all about
behavioral change we've done it before
that should be the priority
so that we can allow the public to
population
to start to have some sense of of of
normality in terms of being able to uh
have
have christmas uh seeing their loved
ones but but i have to be clear that the
normality that i'm describing won't be
normal as usual it could be a new norm
where we have to work
and and and mix within infection control
parameters
but but what the government does today
will determine what happens at christmas
and what the public behavior
is today will determine the infection in
the weeks and months to come because as
i said
we've seen this dramatic change in just
two months